في ايران ايضا الاحتجاجات متواصله رغم
الحملات القمعيه التي ينفذها نظام خامنئي
في حق المتظاهرين من اعتقالات ومداهمات
وقطع الانترنت عن رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الحكومه الايرانيه تقف عاجزه
امام الزخم الكبير للمظاهرات التي تعم كل
ارجاء البلاد منذ مقتل مساء امينه حيث كان
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي دور كبير في نشر
رساله المتظاهرين وتوثيق الاحداث وايضا
توجيه اهداءات لكل الايرانيين للخروج
والتعبير عن حورياتهم فحركت الاحتجاجات
الاخيره في ايران تعتبر الاضخم منذ عقود
ولافت للنظر فيها هو ان من يخرج الى
الشوارع هم في المقام الاول ايرانيون وان
ايرانيات من جيل الشباب استخدام فئه
الشباب الايراني وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
منهم قدرات تحليليه افضل كما منحهم من
الصلاه التعبير عن مطالبهم وشجاعه للتصريح
بارائهم فوفقا للارقام الرسميه الصادره عن
صحيفه جاف اليوميه الايرانيه فان 93% من
المحتاجين تقل اعمارهم عن الخامسه
والعشرين وقد انتشرت المظاهرات الهائله في
طول البلاد وعرضها من خلال بعض مقاطع
الفيديو التي وافقت ما لا يقل عن 300
احتجاج في ايران وفقه مصادر غربيه في
المقابل امتصطع السلطات في الحد من
استخدام الانترنت رغم انها قامت بقطعه عده
مرات الى خلق الحركه الاحتجاجيه في مهدتها
[موسيقى]